favori du second tour à
varennes-vauzelles olivier sico et sa
liste de gauche ont récolté 41 % des
voix le 15 mars le même score que le
candidat communiste en 2014 qui avait
alors été battu
de quoi l'inciter à la prudence les
électeurs nous ont mis effectivement
largement en tête les contacts que nous
avons pu avoir et que nous commençons à
avoir malgré la difficulté nous montrent
qu'effectivement il ya une vraie attente
de changement d'une liste renouvelée
d'une liste vraiment au service des
dévots et lien donc on est confiant mais
on ne crie pas victoire
en deuxième position la maire sortante
isabelle bonicel recueille 28 2% des
suffrages loin des 60 % de l'élection
partielle de 2015 ou l'union lui avait
permis de l'emporter
le résultat du premier tour c'est vrai
qu'a été un peu difficile à accepter
mais l'espace de 24 heures à l'espace de
reprendre un petit peu le bilan
la problématique de 40 60 elle est
toujours là mais maintenant c'est cette
division qui a posé de problème car
cette année quatre listes étaient
présentes au premier tour dont trois
issus de la précédente majorité philippe
morand à renoncer
mais catherine robin chauveau ancienne
adjointe poursuit le combat forte de ses
10 9,1 pour cent
on a passé le premier tour on était
plutôt content d'avoir réussi d'avoir
percé comme ça et on s'est dit qu'on
pouvait pas en rester là qu'il fallait
qu'on aille porter notre projet jusqu'au
bout face à
si les volets lien confirme les
équilibres du premier tour la ville
pourrait donc rebasculer à gauche un
symbole dans ce bastion communiste
pendant 70 ans tombé en 2014
y a pas de revanche y a pas de
stigmatisation ya pas de normal il ya un
projet qui est soutenu par les veaux et
les allées voter lienne et nous on va
essayer de l'incarner et le faire le
faire construire avec eux et donc c'est
ça notre notre objectif c'est pas il n'y
a pas d'esprit de revanche dans notre
candidature cette triangulaire reflète
surtout les affrontements du dernier
mandat
une majorité qui éclatent deux années de
budget bloquer cette fois isabelle
bonicel n'entend pas revivre cette
nouvelle expérience
je me dis que ça a été compliqué mais
que ça ne peut pas être plus compliqué
que cela l'a été pendant les six
dernières années et un deuxième mandat
ne me semble nécessaire pour arriver
justement à aller au bout des projets
pour catherine robin chauveau aussi il
est temps de sortir des années de crise
et pour elle cela passe par un
changement de maire il ya un besoin
d'apaisement il ya un besoin de dépasser
les clivages et un besoin de rassembler
la population sur des vraies vrai projet
sur une concertation sur une
planification des choses beaucoup de
pédagogie du respect voilà rien n'est
donc joué à varennes-vauzelles car même
si les écarts sont importants l'histoire
politique récente de la ville a montré
que tout peut encore basculer